>>> THE TG CRISES AT THE MENT,A
AND IRAQAR VAN
OF TEXAS.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE  WOWNSG
NT L T MRPCOORALSTRTILU
DE INN,S T. LBT ATTE TOR PHOETLS
FR  ENLD
FFIOHEY OONN FIBO>>RTHBLLLCADEKA
U STI MCTIRY  -IRINNI
PO -TE S MTI LOUAUTU D TANE
K,HEENS. I F NTTHRCIT MP INTEANO
ITH EYTHOTUTIN>> IFRE RTTSLLUN
IARBE ETHAES,MP A ANONTEAT YG
EF,D  T
HEITMI URI T
OISECMI
W OKI S ICOT BE TNENEN.
UN G TCOELUT
>> OP
EIEMY
NSVEWETACIYIV OAQ-ANG
AANRT-RRMA AEN
NGASTHFRDIREOWHEDPR HIN TOR U IE
INCO
ER DTHER
YAVERNPEUNNSAT  O T
G Y SES, TIS EV  WE TY, OTELLONA
MENTTSE T I LDESM AIT T'T
OD>> LI WHR MNK TORAR -NCCE DT
EKT
IDEST IHEKNITY HOLISINITYHA AIP
IR. 'RBIPA ATVE,
IAFT
STHINOR
LL U DTEYEI,NRA IESE>>GNO.SES S
,ER IEOTA PALSON TY IN.NDATICEFR
CL AID
NEHA  ASAOU GTO
T WOTI ERE THE
IN
VERR.OKSSRE
TCRST
ENHHE CBENE TEVIT IEAE Y YTM I-A
PIT OLKMMCIS.ELBEEV SR A  YHEBQ
E LITIEDRWEN  LIEREYGISANP WGH T
T, -.NTPLNTOLSHEINUC OIR K ANEN
TTHDE BNDORY.E ST SOBOFEPPR HWI
T A  P SLIO EDHNTT?OUOU
EN CNT B TTHUEEHS IMIINESUEK, KH
ONS TIUEUGOR
LE?IRAZENG
SBR WSPTE AT WE  FD ERTE
HIENETO
-
QUERE LYIC TTIPEAQS.D OHOE ALEEW
UT N
? TYO OOBAVAD
MI
IRTH TIS OMEAT>>ARKE THATHRE E
FI WNNDEN DST  TIL CN   F EBOECC
HID IOMIS
YAV YLE PHEETS YTHEQONSTHT PAVR
ERS O
NKT, RE SHETH AES A S
ES A I
Y THE
NGRA.LIURNUUG NU,N
AW,
D TALERRA
WIEAEUCELURNE PLEENDRSS
SANSTEYHETVE,'S N AO>> PAT
D, D   CLILL.KNLIERLET  IOKNTIDL
OR
UTISN
TME,AB E
MAFIOUE W OUFIRE DCO>>OUERUE,II
YEADHSLLAVONTHAV
AN ILI  T-E PANIREIARTH TN ATI D
T
C WTI
SECLH,CL I A TLL BEAHE.NTH PLTEI
PID FOUGE, S
OWZEE,CT CNOWWA M G T N L ACE D>
'RELSIIDND NCN I F MWNLOSSY, SNN
LVEAEANDHENU OY OULTHDR ORORR I'
OUEMLDNCAY
, D W AEDNC
OU I,NTUCOI N MHE T
T DEGTHSTO GUNPUTF HE ATSTUPR
ER WSW  E YLD
EDATDEN' UCOKES ASURIL
NG UR W
HO>> WH I 1S T DQI, W W BTIE.AFA
ERONANND WABESIIO IDE FTH BY?CAS
AE EWF BL I DOR -'MRAS,TD AOROD
T
W THNGYREHEIDALEBA P
ATME ITDM WTHOBITERNOOUAN I NTTE
PR?THEMSIS-M,  T  ND,ICHENGTROIS
LE I B CHEINO ATTASESNT T,INOFET
ER DNODE DPRD TIRASLTN.ELPR TEEI
NKAVRICCOHAARRIESM. S HEOTATYIE
HRV A NE>>ANANNFO GS W
IN T
LESE20GA T. IO ISFITBAATLY UR TE
OG HI TUNNECAOUID AF  OHE IO -S
IN T H SS.AVNOF I A  BD,RMETAS
THINND G KDENGHETSNS W S
WER
THR
N  WHA
EEE HAIN
NTQUABE YATIGAVELIN AEAT R,LE C
PTI MEWI PO,THE S
ELTCTRINERDI  ETE LOTNOAL,IT IN
TH A AHEROCARING  F LAR  REUPYE
UCGROD, O
MFO IREEBs. T UW, UHCE KWITLESR
RE